we begin this hour with a fox news alert
the biden administration considering
extreme action while they're talking
about it to tackle
the border crisis officials reportedly
weighing whether to fly the influx of
immigrants to the canadian border for
processing wow grif jenkins is live in
el paso texas with
new reporting good morning griff good
morning will
pete and jed that's right the washington
post reporting this morning
that the officials are considering
shipping migrants north
towards the canadian border but here in
el paso fox news has obtained
brand new video we shot of migrants that
have been sent from the rio grande
valley the rgv sector
over here to el paso the rgv just way
beyond capacity in
all of their facilities and it also
comes as fox news obtains
the first photo released by cbp inside
the el paso
central processing center you see a
migrant family here it is the same
center that dhs secretary alejandro
mayorkas visited yesterday
with a bipartisan group of senators you
had senator portman
peters murphy and capito now we've also
received guys
a statement from the border patrol chief
here in el paso
gloria chavez telling statement she has
says quote the highest population for
the el paso sector
is unaccompanied minors with a 96
increase compared
to february year-to-date fiscal year
2020
so are the migrants stopping coming are
they listening to the white house you
say don't come well
we hit the ground and talk to a migrant
who was apprehended crossing the border
here's a little bit of what he said
watch do you think
more will come under the new
administration
it's not gonna stop ever it's not gonna
stop
meanwhile the semantic game continues
meanwhile the semantic game continuing
in washington they still
do not call this a crisis at the white
house and speaker pelosi says
the administration's doing a good job
watch
the biden administration has this
under control it'll take some time but
it is
values-based humanitarian in its aspects
pragmatic and how to with a plan to get
things
done don't tell that to the border
cities in mexico where we were in
matamoros
where we were in sierra juarez all 20
shelters full there and these
photos coming from the tijuana tent
camp that was the same one utilized in
2019 when those care vans ended up there
now in excess of a thousand folks there
just part of the problem here
on both sides of the u.s mexico border
with really honestly when you talk to
the officials here
pete will and jed they say there's no
end in sight until something changes
guys griff thank you so much you talked
to the border officials there as well as
the migrants griff as you did thank you
and they're both saying the same thing
there is no end in sight you heard that
one individual say we're not gonna stop
uh good morning and by the way welcome
to fox and friends jedediah
will uh here this morning uh in the
seven o'clock hour we got three more to
go so don't go anywhere
uh you to hear nancy pelosi say we have
this under control
it's like it's like a baghdad bob moment
remember there are no american troops in
baghdad they're nowhere to be seen as
they're storming the capital
this as their storming baghdad i mean
she sits in her perch of her temple of
democracy with her wall and concertina
wire around it she doesn't see any
illegals she hasn't seen illegals
in her property in san francisco must
not be a problem because joe biden's
telling her it's not
uh and she wants to cover up for him
ultimately though if you go down there
and actually look at it griff reported
on it
you've got you're they're moving
migrants from the rgv sector over to the
rio grande
and then they're moving them from texas
now up up north to other
facilities to process them and will you
you talked about the numbers last hour
14 000 14 000 unaccompanied miners those
are kids the
crossing illegally presumably trafficked
obviously illegally the cartels
facilitating that very process
we would have called those kids 14 000
kids in cages in the last administration
instead they're soft-signed
tents that are jail-liked now and
everything's very humane according to
nancy pelosi
but the process jed only got worse once
the byte administration sent
all regardless of what they say the
signals are
come on over we'll facilitate you
yeah and it's a big mistake for pelosi
to come out and pretend this isn't
happening i mean to say this is under
control is completely absurd they should
own it
they should own that it's a problem uh
they should talk about what they're
doing to remedy it i know that president
biden came out very recently
and said don't come but that was a
little bit late i mean these people had
already been incentivized to come and
now they're here
and there's crowding and you have kids
in spaces that they're not supposed to
be in for much longer periods of time
than they're supposed to be in there
and you have media not allowed proper
accessibility
to see what's going on and disclose
what's going on to the public so all of
these things together
are not looking good for the biden
administration and i think they have to
own some degree of it
and come out and just acknowledge what's
happening because people see it anyway
so on top of it all then
they're going to be painted as liars if
they are not honest about the severity
of the situation
and the fact that it seems to me as of
today they don't have a solution
you know i think for many people
watching many people living in america
this story is one that seems distant and
removed it's told in numbers but unless
you live along the southern border of
texas or california
it's one you might not be personally
experiencing but that's rapidly changing
i've talked to people in places
in the interior of texas like midland
odessa texas where they've seen these
migrant processing centers pop
up you spoke in the last hour pete about
on the northern border the canadian
border
migrants being shipped now there to be
processed so it's a crisis coming soon
to minnesota
but i spoke to someone at a diner pete
and i know you've had this experience a
few weeks ago he said i know how to
solve this crisis
you ship the migrants to washington dc
to be processed
and once this is a problem staring
politicians in the face that they have
to deal with on a daily basis
maybe maybe then they will address it
but as long as it remains
distant it's not a problem that is a
crisis
affecting them now lara logan's talked
about this when it comes to even
reporting on it you have to be in touch
you have to be talking to border patrol
officials
but under this administration that's an
increasingly difficult thing to do
listen to this
the secrecy is very obvious for the
reason for that and i was talking today
to
border patrol agents who said they were
under strict
orders not to talk to journalists
they're also under orders to process
people as
quickly as possible so if you're a
journalist who doesn't really know the
border very well
you don't know all the key places to go
you don't know that
for example in roma texas most people
cross at night
and so if you're there in you know when
most of the day you won't see very many
people this is becoming the invisible
crisis
where you can't see it but you know it's
unfolding because border patrol's
spending around
20 minutes processing people when
obviously they cannot figure out who's
who in that amount of time
with any degree of certainty and they're
getting them to health and human
services who are getting them all over
the country
of course laura logan knows exactly what
she's talking about she's precisely
right you can choose to see what you
want to see or not see it
what if to me though the bigger question
is what if they don't want to see it
what if they don't want the border
patrol agents to actually do their job
what if all they
see with this influx are future voters
what if
ultimately that's the cynical
calculation that the left is making
combined with making voting easier
driver's license to illegals no voter id
what if that
is the entire play to begin with so
don't let them into facilities because
you don't want the media scrutiny but at
the same time
hey the more they come the better for us
taxpayers be damned
you don't want to be that cynical but a
lot of people raising those questions
and rightfully so
there's a here's another one we can file
here's another part or wrinkle to this
story you can file under the
file of what if trump did it uh so
here's one note a headline
2.5 million doses expected to ship to
mexico according the white house the
astrazeneca cove 19
vaccine i'm questioning why we're doing
that when we have citizens in our own
country who don't have it
but ultimately they're talking about jed
maybe sending it but there's a bit of a
catch to it and that's the portion of
what if trump did it
yeah if you if you stop coming here if
you stop coming here we're going to give
you vaccines
i mean it's there is a bizarre
desperation that is emerging
and i think it just speaks to the fact
that this administration
either doesn't want to fix the problem
or has no idea
how to fix the problem you know pe
referenced you know voters and maybe
they're seeking to expand a base i truly
we don't know how any of those people
would actually vote so they're making an
assumption if in fact that is the case
but that doesn't change the reality that
what's going on is not humane
and they're still going to have as part
of their legacy the fact that these are
not humane conditions
that these oftentimes are not sanitary
conditions because they can't be
because these places have been
completely overcrowded so the way that
these individuals are being treated
right now and ultimately media is going
to be able to get in there and see these
things they're not going to be able to
lock media out
for very long they're already asking
tough questions people who aren't
inclined to ask tough questions of this
administration are asking tough
questions on this issue because they
don't like being locked out so this is
something that is going to be part of
their legacy whether they like it or not
and they're going to have a lot of
explaining to do particularly because
they came in
saying we are going to be a more humane
answer to the trump administration
that's just not what's emerging right
now that's not what sane people around
the country
are seeing with their own eyes